I just explained the thinking behind
this decision not to stand against
conservative candidates because I would
have thought that either you accept that
the brexit party is going to take votes
with the Conservatives and we'll make
brexit less likely to happen or you
don't so you either stand everywhere or
you stand in any way yeah well I think
the fear we had was that by standing up
against the Tories we might create
another hung parliament or worse give
power to the Labour Party or in some
kind of arrangement perhaps with the Lib
Dems and those two parties are hostile
to brexit so the key for us was to try
and get a leave sympathetic majority of
parliamentarians in Parliament and you
know we could have cut that cake in a
number of different ways but the way we
decided to do it was to simply stand
down against the Tories in those 317
seats
I mean you're talking about the risk of
a hung parliament yeah you really
worried about the risk of the hung
parliament why is the brexit party still
standing in some of those marginals will
actually walk held by Labour MP I mean
what we hoped was that the Tories would
respond positively to the enormous ly
generous offer that we made two weeks
ago which was for them to stand down and
150 old seats that they haven't won for
over a hundred years in the Labour
heartlands were actually you know the
brexit party has a very good choice and
we would stand down against them and in
that way we would have had a very strong
leave majority in parliament and they
didn't take up that offer
so we unilaterally put that into place
in effect and we still hoped that the
Tories might stand down and as we now
know that was a forlorn hope because
they haven't so we're going head-to-head
with the Tories in these heartlands and
Soviet I mean it's the truth that you
know some in the brexit party or someone
the brexit side of the debate what
wouldn't breaks it to happen more than
anything so that's why there's been this
pressure to stand down but Nigel frosh
loves the limelight a little bit too
much he's not willing to give it all up
and so that's why you're in this kind of
half a in half out situation no I don't
think so I think we're all in it for
brexit we genuinely are you know if you
look at the collection of MEP s we've
got with a bunch of people that I know
best obviously we're from all parts of
the political spectrum but we've come
together because we just want briggs it
done and we want to dump properly not
the way Boris wants
do it hang on a minute so I'm gonna be
on there you don't brakes it done
properly not the way Borgia wants to do
it so why are you not standing against
conservatives I mean Nigel Franz I spent
the last month or so saying that his
deal isn't brexit at all well the labor
pipe just came back to where I said the
Labour Party in Lib Dems that overtly
hostile to breaks it so we've got to get
you know there's no prospect of the
brexit party forming a government you
know we've got to be realistic about
that so we've got to try and bring the
Tories under pressure to do the right
thing and the only way to do that is to
give them a majority not a very big
majority in parliament with us having a
handful of seats and then keeping them
honest what we really need to do is get
the prime minister to pivot away from
the withdrawal agreement which is you if
you've read my Twitter feed you'll know
I think is subjugation of the United
Kingdom so you know I see the withdrawal
agreement is much worse than remain
frankly and that so we've got to get the
Prime Minister to move away and remain
is better than than the worst Johnson's
Dale I do yeah I do think it's it's much
better because if you think about it
under Boris Johnson's deal we're going
to leave Northern Ireland bereft we're
going to leave the European Party
position that remaining in the EU is
better than Boris Johnson's deal that
may or may not be our position that's
certainly my view when I look at the
withdrawal agreement so why on earth you
standing down in conservative seats them
because we we've got they're not hostile
the Tories are not hostile to breaks it
we've got to make pushing the deal and I
think remains better than truly present
one of one of the declarations on which
Nigel based a lot of his reliance was
the declaration that Boris Johnson made
last Sunday that we wouldn't be in
transition beyond December 2020 and that
we would in effect get a Canada style
arrangement rather than a political
declaration still have the withdrawal
agreement which is in your view worse
now I think it is absolutely I think
it's highly dangerous but we need to
make sure that Boris Johnson does the
promise that he made last Sunday and we
leave the European Union cleanly the
risk with the redrawn agreement is that
with the ECJ calling all the shots as we
go through the transition a transition
phase
we end up in some kind of locks
with the European Union in perpetuity so
we've got to get a number of seats to
make sure that that doesn't happen now
and there's been lots of allegations
that the Conservative Party had been
offering jobs to brexit party candidates
in return for them standing down the met
have pronounced a statement today saying
that they received two allegations of
electoral fraud and malpractice in
relation to the 2019 election now
they're not saying what the substance of
those allegations are about but in your
understanding is it correct that the
government has been offering members of
the brexit party jobs well sadly no job
was ever offered to me no inducement was
offered to me but I am aware that a
number of my colleagues have been
pressed and ad and Widdecombe for
example I know was offered some sort of
negotiating position with the Tory party
from number 10 someone from number 10
call and and I know they've been lots of
conversations going on and discussions
and pressure has been brought to bear
and how many people are we talking about
here I don't know is the is the franco i
don't know how but I know it's been
going on because the concept of party
says it's flatly untrue they said is
absolutely false are you saying that
they're lying well I'm saying then being
economical with the truth for sure
absolutely it has been going on without
a shadow of a doubt okay okay
and interesting stuff and now just
looking ahead to the election coming up
is there a practical part of candidate
standing in your constituency no in
Fulham no there isn't sadly well I'm
torn
Greg hands was at University with me and
I know him to be a good man and I'm a
vote for Greg because he's a Tory but if
I don't vote for Greg then I'm afraid
I'll probably put for the first time
since 1983 when I first voted I'll
probably put something sort of spoiling
on the ballot paper to the effect of
brexit party with a big tick and put it
in the box and you feel frustrated but
because the party's policy you you're
not going on to face well I think with
the benefit of hindsight you know maybe
we shouldn't have stood 317 candidates
down with the benefit of hindsight
because the Tories haven't responded
positively to it
they haven't stood down and assured a
proper leave mandate in Parliament I
think Fulham's not you know one of the
seats that we would have won to be
honest and
but we are where we are and we will
fight a good election I think we've got
274 candidates standing and I know when
any MPs I think we will I actually think
we will on how many do you reckon then
well I don't know but I'd be surprised
if we don't get at least five and I'd be
very pleased if we get twenty and
probably everyone watching me right now
is going yeah right that's a good chance
you know if you think about this
election it's not just it's not just
split down party lines if Dan Briggs is
not and remain lines too so you've got
multiple things going on and and seats
could be won on as low as 25% of the
vote cast or 30% of the vote cast so you
won't get these you know thumping
majorities coming through as we have
done in the past in each seat and
national polls won't tell you the
picture either because we're not
standing in a lot of the seats so you've
got to look at it on a constituency by
constituency basis and I think there's a
real possibility of us winning seats
absolutely